welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and dr strange in the multiverse of
madness is streaming now on digital and
we are learning all this movies deep
dark secrets that we didn't catch in our
initial breakdown in may some of it
horrifying details that they left out of
the movie with little traces of these
things left in it really the more we
learn about this movie and the more we
go back through it the scarier and the
cooler it gets it's time we go back
through this literally frame by frame to
talk about this many more details that
we didn't catch before giving us a total
of people
this total there's so much in this for
me let's break it all down in this video
so everything is covered and you will be
sorcerer supreme of the missable details
and multiverse of madness the opening
marvel studios title card alone has an
insane amount of deeper layers of
meaning that could be its own video
we're just gonna talk about it all here
by this point you may have seen how it
has been updated as usual to include the
shot of oneness scarlet witch powerup
from monovision episode nine the first
time footage from a disney plus show has
made its way into the title card we also
see doctor strange with the time stone
magic strange fighting thanos and
infinity war making the same banned arm
post that defender strange will do as a
zombie in this movie we see wong in
endgame saying you wanted more strange's
last words to tony and endgame holding
up that one finger then the family team
up shot from the one division finale
which if you look closely at that also
includes a nod to sam raimi's past film
oz of great and powerful the wicked
witch of the west being a very strong
analog for wanda in this film now the m
and the a ultimately shows strange in
the final shot as he's walking up the
steps in the 2016 film and wanda when
she nearly killed thanos and end game
the most fearsome demonstration of her
power in the infinity saga but the e is
wong celebrating in the fighting ring
from sheng chi but most interesting of
all these on the surface before we see
the family shot they added a shot from
black panther tinted at purple showing
t'challa and shuri sharing their
handshake and salute something that
wouldn't be that big of a deal all these
shots are just highlight rules from past
films but folks i checked every other
marvel title from the past year
multiverse of madness is the only one so
far to include this shot they
deliberately wanted to include t'challa
and shuri sharing a moment someone from
marvel studies decided fans should
really see these two together i think
it's a deliberate clue from the marvel
studios team hinting that shuri might
possibly bear t'challa's legacy in black
panther wakanda forever and finally
whereas in the past it's t'challa's
kinetic blast in the r that clears all
the letters out this time it is a sling
ring portal that spreads outward almost
a way of sucking us into another realm
of madness this movie opens by diving
into the gap junction which 838
christine palmer later calls the space
between universes it may be based on the
nexus of all realities in marvel comics
which is a similar concept but here it
is designed to look like the ruins of a
church light pouring in through stained
glass 16 broken pathways leading to the
altar of the book of vashanti also a way
of showing how all these different
realities are pathways leading to this
one junction but the fact that this is
all destroyed is a reflection of the
incursions that have taken a toll on the
multiverse originally this film was
going to open with a completely
different scene mordo coming off of his
too many sorcerers mission in the 2016
film post-credits scene tracks wanda
down to her mountain cabin from the one
of vision post credit scene but wanda
beheads mordo and she later presents his
head to strange and according to
screenwriter mike waldron would even
puppeteer his headless corpse actually
if you look to the screen x poster for
the film we saw imagery in the corner of
that poster showing this original
opening scene of course this was dark as
hell so it was removed and this way they
made wanda's villainous turn more of a
reveal but in a way the theatrical cut
still opens with wanda because the first
character we see on screen is the ribbon
monster which we later learn is wanda's
puppet as it rages past us in the
opening frames you can even see her
runes already visible when he pauses at
the right second we actually learned
that animators designed gargantos with
elizabeth olsen's features and if you
look at this monster too from the way it
roars at them and even its opening grunt
all these things bear a bit of
resemblance to elizabeth olsen's acting
they clearly used her as a visual and
auditory reference this whole monster is
clearly designed to be a marionette with
its cords tangled and it's super pissed
off defender strange and america chavez
flee this monster defender strange
freezes it little vfx details i
appreciate here it's tentacles that it
used to clutch the piece of debris
freeze and snap off and that is what
causes it to trip also as defender
strange does his backward sleep he uses
sorcery to guide his leap and cushion
his landing this spell is actually
called the vaulting boots of valtor and
we saw mordo use these in the 2016 film
the difference of course is this
strangest magic is white compared to the
orange color in 616. the opening words
of this movie are in spanish
it is the first mcu film to open with
spanish america chavez is the first
openly lgbtq plus latinx female
superhero and her star emblazoned jacket
has amoris amore stitched in along with
a pried pin defender strange was
confirmed by sam raimi to be from
universe 617 which the comics was formed
when spider gwen from earth 65 meets
gwen from 616 and prevents that gwen
from being thrown off the bridge by
green goblin and by doing that diverges
616 gwen into a timeline 617 where she
merges with venom and becomes spider
woman they approach the book of vashanti
which in the comics is a book of
positive counterspells i like the color
coding of it the dark hold is often
colored with red sorcery the book of
ashanti emits a pure blue the same color
tone as america chavez's star portals a
little hint that the spell contained
within is contained within america
herself defender strange tells america
i'm so sorry this is the only way in the
grand calculus of the multiverse
your sacrifice is worth more than your
life he quotes 616 strange from infinity
war there was no other way and strange
from spider-man no way home in the grand
calculus of the multiverse
their sacrifice means infinitely more
than their lives i also love how this
monster impales him with the killing
blow precisely as he says the word life
your sacrifice is worth more than your
life he cuts life short the irony
america gets across to the book of
ashanti partly by american ninja
warrioring on one of those monsters
ribbon arms but that monster snares her
but does not kill her because remember
wanda does not want america dead yet but
strange cuts are free and they both
spiraled through one of the star portals
in a little detail in the transition
here as that camera rotates from
defender strange's corpse to an upside
down shot of the 616 strange waking up
the transition happens so that their
faces are aligned 616 strange woke up
precisely as defender strange died kind
of like how when you die in a dream
that's the moment you wake up light
streams into strange's bedroom from
curtains that cast some undulating
shadows evoking the arms of the ribbon
monster attacking him moments before
this movie establishes a rule that
whenever mcu characters have dreamed
they are peering into the lives of their
alternate selves this recalls tony
stark's dream in infinity war last night
i dreamt
we had a kid
so real
we named him after your eccentric uncle
uh what was his name morgan and tony did
end up having a daughter named morgan
and the nightmares that wanda gave the
avengers in age of ultron including
tony's premonition of their deaths
because tony even hinted at that in
endgame i had a vision i didn't want to
believe it
dauber's dreaming strange looks over at
his wrist watch the one christine gave
him and broke in the 2016 film but he
left that face broken symbolizing the
unhealable wound of his broken hands but
if you listen closely
[Music]
it does still tick and now if you look
closely you can actually see its date it
reads tuesday november 23rd now november
23rd only falls on a tuesday in the year
2021 in recent years or in the next few
years but in the mcu timeline this is
presumably november 2024 which might be
why disney plus lists this between
eternals which is in fall 2024 in
hawkeye which is christmas time 2024
however of course the events of
multiverse of madness are definitely
supposed to happen after spider-man no
way home which also ends sometime around
christmas 2024. because strange and
wonks say in this movie how much
experience do you guys have with
multiverse we have experience of the
multiverse most recently there was an
incident with spider-man what man kevin
feige also said multiverse of madness
was after no way home and that allowed a
spell to go wrong in spider-man no way
home which leads to the entire
multiverse going quite mad in in this so
how do we explain this well the end
universe answer is tom is a flat circle
and in loki citadel at the end of all
time where the multiverse first
fractured the rules of causality were
broken but the real answer folks is that
whoever makes the disney plus playlist
and most of the people at marvel studios
are just confused about their own
chronology and they constantly screw it
up so let's move on strange uses magic
to tie his necktie just a reminder that
his injured hands are still somewhat
clumsy on his way through the sanctum he
passes his piano remember in the sanctum
in the alternate post incursion
university visits the piano will be
instrumental
in his music duel with sinister strange
strange enters the church for the
wedding he passes these two boys who run
to a mother who just bears a pretty
strong resemblance to elizabeth olsen i
don't know if it was intentional but it
is a little echo of his coming conflict
with a mother and her two elusive sons
dr nick west returns to the 2016 film
revealing he dusted in the blip and when
he returned he found he lost both his
cats oh and also his brother i guess
what keeps me up at night is wondering
did it have to happen that way
was there any other path a lion of
course meant to guilt strange for
surrendering the time stone to thanos
but also if west is literally up at
night it means that he is losing sleep
because he's dreaming of other lives
where he still has his cats and his
brother the way that west knows what
strange did on titan is likely due to
scott lang's podcast series big me
little me on this powered life revealed
to be in the mcu in ms marvel one of
many reasons you should absolutely watch
that show because it is awesome and yes
i know scott lang was not on titan but
he knows the other avengers they told
him and he told the public shree
insurance christine's water into wine
quite jesus-like a running gag after he
refilled thor's beer in ragnarok which i
will always say is the best use of magic
steven regrets letting christine go but
she says it was never gonna work out
between us why not
because steven
you have to be the one holding the knife
yes he has to be the one holding the
knife strange being the scalpel holding
surgeon this knife imagery comes back
throughout the film and remember this
script was written by michael waldron
and it parallels the love is a dagger
monologue that he wrote for loki love
is a dagger it's a weapon
to be wielded far away
or up close you can see yourself in it
it's beautiful
until it makes you bleed but ultimately
when you reach for it
it isn't real ultimately sylvie was the
one left holding the dagger in that
series she cut loki loose as strange
does for christine when strange goes out
on the balcony to see the commotion in
the bottom right of frame is a billboard
for rogers the musical the broadway show
from hawkeye billboards like these also
showed up in no way home he pulls out
the red handkerchief stuff in his pocket
revealing the cloak of levitation hidden
in plain sight and i love this maneuver
because like the alcohol related tricks
this is practical it really does feel
like a classical magician illusion and
he changed his wardrobe mid-air similar
to tony stark's famous free-fall suit up
in avengers strange saves a woman and
her baby by summoning a giant feline
head this is in front of a red
storefront in mcleod's books the 838
version of which shows up outside the
838 sanctum both named after bob mccloud
long time marvel comics artist strange d
cloaks the monster as gargantos who's a
lesser known name or villain originally
it's gonna be schuma gorath what was
renamed because shimogorath is an h.p
lovecraft invention licensed by heroic
signatures along with characters like
conan the barbarian producer richie
palmer revealed that they used a scan of
olson's eye to create this eyeball and
foreshadow the reveal of wanda as the
puppet master you can see in its pain
and its rage it's shock capillaries in
the eyeball this is all wanda's emotion
and i love how gargantos has these two
gills beneath the eye when he roars the
flaps open making the sound of a jazz
trumpet
the bus that he throws at him has an ad
for la jave coffee unlock a better day a
hand to add strange's upcoming quest to
use a watch to unlock the back door is a
key nearby is an ad for the magic of
celestial tea and when strange jumps on
a taxi there's a sign behind him for
stan lee's which i just think is a nod
to stan lee whose real name was stanley
lieber and in the 2008 hulk movie they
paid tribute to him with stanley's pizza
garganto scales the side of a building
raimi calling back doc ox scaling the
side of the building in 2004 spider-man
2 screenwriter michael waltrim cameos is
the best man in the wedding party
strange contrasts these big hands to
tear a lamppost at the sidewalk but
notice they're scaly and they have four
fingers each making this a fantasy beast
i'm assuming the same feline that
strange used to catch the car and he
spears gargantos eye
[Music]
in the skewered eyes visual is an homage
to rainey's flying eyeball and evil dead
too they bring up spider-man we have
experience of the multiverse most
recently there was an incident with
spider-man does he look like a spider no
no more like a man climbs wool shoots
wet yeah bingo out of his butt
recalling the confusion over where
exactly to wire peter parker's webbing
comes out of him in no way home like
does it just come out of your wrists or
does it come out of anywhere else only
only the wrists and again just to
clarify despite the memory wipe spell in
no way home that spell only affects
strange and wong knowing that spider-man
is peter parker they still know
spider-man exists and have memories of
spider-man joining them in their
adventures they have just had their
memories wiped so they don't know who is
under the mask like notice they never
say the name peter in the scene they
bury the corpse of the defender strange
on the sanctum roof setting up a nifty
plot device to call back in the third
act just some nice economy of story
there and they recognize the runes as
witchcraft let me know anyone who's
faced such a thing
i think i might
yeah the music here is the one division
bewitch theme composed by the lopez's
for the second episode
[Music]
we see the same house in kitchen from
one division's later episodes and billy
and tommy return wearing red and green
to match their comic identities of
wiccan and speed they also have wrist
watches matching their colors there's a
hamster cage on the countertop the
hamster named max or maxi short for
maxim off probably to replace poor
sparky now this bedroom tuck in seems a
bit surreal and it's because they
constructed it with footage shot on the
wandevision set but it's been flipped in
one division episode 9 billy's bed and
the telescope were on the left tommy's
bed the skeleton decoration and the
stoplight were on the right but here it
is the opposite but they did not flip
the poster highest on the middle wall
they just slid it from right to left
they also added some house lights on the
homes outside across the street actually
in the shot of wanda looking over at
tommy it is literally the same shot from
wandavision reversed that is the same
shot of julian hilliard but they mapped
in a new elizabeth olsen from this wanda
abruptly awakens and within the same
shot the lighting and color tone shift
from warm and golden to cold and grey
tone showing how her comforty dream
fades in a cold reality a motif that we
also see in thor 11 thunder with gore a
desaturated villain mourning his family
want to clip some tree branches apples
right eventually yes the trees are not
yet bearing fruit a metaphor for herself
as her efforts to locate her sons have
been fruitless apples of course also
have been associated with the forbidden
fruit of the garden of eden where eve
was villainized for giving into evil
leading to the historic sexist view of
women as more prone to evil of course
the poisoned apple also the weapon of
choice the witch queen and snow white
which also shows up later this movie and
pruning branches the metaphor used by
the tva to tame the multiverse as wanda
has been clipping or marking off
universes that do not contain their sons
they chat what do you know about the
multiverse the multiverse this had his
theories he believed it was real and
dangerous and she drops the branches
into this crate a close-up showing its
name bjolkers now in the comics window
volker is an academic who along with
reed richards discovers that baron zemo
has traveled back in time this is a 2007
thunderbolts arc but i think this great
close-up might have been from this scene
originally having wanda presenting
mordo's severed head to strange here
like after the illusion faded we might
have returned to this crate and from
this she pulls out the severed head
strange says you could use an avenger
there are other avengers yeah but given
the choice between the archer with the
mohawk and several bug-themed crime
fighters yes referring to hawkeye and
then spider-man ant-man and wasp you
think about it also scarlet scarab just
joined this club as well strangers
helping them we'll get her back on the
lunch box and there actually is an
avengers themed retro lunch box with
scarlet witch on the side with yellow
jacket and daredevil but after outing
herself as knowing more than she should
she uses her red sorcery to warp this
orchard into this burnt hellscape the
red sorcery warping these trees the same
way the building storefronts do in west
view in one vision we see that she is
using the darkhold of course the book of
the damned first introduced in
wanovision and on the page is an eye
visible the center of it this was the
eye that she used to control gargantos
and an eye that shows up in the runes on
the walls of the dark hole the temple
perhaps the eye of kethon whose horned
head adorns the cover of this book in
the background is the burnt ruins of a
structure where that large house was
when the illusion was up this is the
house from the posters showing that
removed opening scene with mordo getting
beheaded notice how wanda's kept her
hands in her pockets before showing her
cards and now we see the tips of her
fingers have turned black from using the
dark hole just as agatha's hands had
turned black when she possessed the dark
hole in wanda vision wanda's wardrobe
has been updated showing some scratches
radiating from the heart region you can
see this better in the camara taj battle
these scratches showing how her breaking
of reality really stems from a broken
heart also the design of her collar
leaves an opening in the shape of
vision's mind stone the thing that she
had to shatter in infinity war and has
never gotten over blaming strange
because his surrender the time stone is
what specifically made that sacrifice
pointless strange says wonder your
children aren't real
you created them using magic that's what
every mother does it is such a good wine
read from olsen here and there's a
little gesture here that's easy to miss
she flutters her eyelids that's what
every mother does yes so she is clapping
back here but she's also showing how
unstable she is [ __ ] taj wong explains
scarlet witch is a being of unfathomable
magic she can rewrite realities she
chooses and is prophesized to either
rule or annihilate the cosmos yes he's
recalling what agatha read from the dark
old your power exceeds that of the
sorcerer supreme it's your destiny to
destroy the world wong as sorcerer's
supreme since strange blip was probably
pretty shook to learn this prophecy
master amir returns in the 2016 film and
we meet sarah who's probably based on
wong's love interest sarah in the comics
as well as rintra a green minotaur
sorcerer from raval in the comics
portals open from the hong kong and
london sanctums the backgrounds of those
portals showing hong kong street and in
london a red phone booth and a double
decker bus i assume stephen grant is
writing it the commentary elders conjure
a spell in the background illuminating
the floor they are actually setting that
mirror dimension trap that wanda springs
by stepping on later wanda's arrival
mirrors that of the wicked witch of the
west in the dark smoke over the emerald
city demanding surrender dorothy a girl
who can transcend realities with shoes
that pack a wallop depending by a
scarecrow who's falling apart a
heartless tin man a lion who finds his
courage a good witch who all seek help
from the imposing men behind the curtain
who are actually phony liars and
ultimately realize there's no place like
home because america realizes that wanda
just needs to go home and when wanda
first appears composer danny elfman
stings it with this horror piano chord
he actually comes back to this for scary
moments with wanda throughout the movie
as she tries to break in one identifies
one weak sorcerer
oh so cool whispering in the ear is
exactly what wanda does to each of the
avengers in age of ultron to corrupt
them and after she breaks in and wrecks
the place she telepathically whispers to
america somewhere in the compound
[Music]
yeah i love this according to disney
plus closed captions wanda is whispering
america in sokovian wanda's native
language the more succobian she sounds
the more of a villainous she reverts to
strange traps wanda in the mirror
dimension which winds up like a toy
music box to get out of it wanda extends
her hands into the broken mirror shards
as if they're water transfiguring
herself into a piece of mirror so that
she can exist in any reflective surface
anywhere similar to the logic of gore's
shadow realm in thor love and thunder if
you haven't seen love and thunder yet
don't worry it's not a spoiler this was
revealed in the trailer for the movie
the guard and hamir get pulled into
puddles meaning the mirror is probably
still stuck in the mirror dimension
somewhere they rush to cover their
reflections but wanda pushes her
contorted body out of a gong looking
like samara in the ring crest with
pennywise and it it's just terrifying
wanda shows the countless universes
where she is still with billy and tommy
every night
the same dream and every morning
the same
nightmare yeah again she says nightmare
with a bit of a russian slash jacobian
accent discovering identity rewinding
her back to the age of ultron times when
she was more of a villain strange
unleashes serpents from his hands an
attack we actually saw strange supreme
do in what if episode 4 notice that when
wanda slices their heads off more grow
in their place kind of like a hydra
strange is literally fighting the hydra
arrow wanda with a hydra onto the
multiverse montage where they give us a
movie called multiverse of madness but
limit the mad multiverse to like 11
seconds these were all actually
identified by the frame store of effects
artists first is the living tribunal
statue world originally going to be a
giant temple or indian statues but they
change it to the living tribunal who is
the three-faced cosmic legal authority
in the marvel comics but here there are
actually several of these heads then
after a world with glowing particles
snaking up into a source there is a
cavern that they originally called the
onslaught canyon world originally going
to be more like the grand canyon like in
no way home but changed to be closer to
the crevice in 127 hours then a mirror
world they went to be a glass world but
here they made it look more like ice
followed by a honeycomb world filled
with giant bees the next added an
underwater coral reef really just to mix
it up and then what they called an alt
new york where they had fish fly into
the cars from the previous world and on
those taxis is an ad for grindhouse
releasing that's the film restoration
company of sam raimi and the movie's
editor bob marowski then a pipe world
with tony stark drones from spider-man
far from home you can see stark stamped
on all those drones and actually
positioned exactly where the taxis were
in the previous world then this hellish
bone dimension where some of the
skeletons are larger than the others if
you notice like there's one giant hand
like the one of the skeleton thorita's
battle ropes with in thor love and
thunder notice how a lot of skeletons
are climbing up like trying to keep off
of the floor of this world like floor is
lava in moon night in the duat the goal
was to keep off of the sand because that
would doom you to eternal damnation that
might be what's happening in boone world
here then one the artist called savage
world where a t-rex fights a triceratops
a nod to the x-men comics savage land
then a comic book world which they said
was deliberately different from the
animation style of what if they focus
more on the hard lines between the
colors then there's this mysterious
post-apocalyptic world new york city in
ruins which they said was what the city
would look like if the avengers lost the
battle of new york then a cube world
which they said was very technical
because they had to attach hair on each
cube they actually had to reduce the
number of cubes make them larger because
too many slices ended up being way too
gory then the paint world that they
refer to later it's very hard to eat in
here then hydra world this is new york
stuck in the 1930s where hydra took over
because notice the hydra logo on that
blimp made a whole video explaining what
this timeline could be and how it could
bring red skull back for secret wars
then a world with futuristic pyramids
and stonehenge-like configurations then
this blade runner futuristic world then
a more pristine futuristic cloud city
and then another hellish realm with lava
rivers that michael waldron said was not
most apart from star wars and then they
spit out in 838 where instead of lava
rivers are waterfalls from the empire
state building there's greenery covering
all the buildings and overhead some
rainbow covered clouds you'll notice
many of the pedestrians carry umbrellas
maybe these clouds are on an artificial
clockwork to water all the plant life
and people carry the umbrellas to brace
for it all these people also wear
neutral colors maybe as a fashion trend
to keep the eyes on colorful splendor of
nature instead of what we wear in
addition to going on red and stopping on
green the taxis that drive on these
streets are blue the color of reed
richards if you pause the taxis it
passes behind pizza papa's cart and
they're marked with three credits per
mile suggesting that reed richards and
the other geniuses of this universe
helped put currency on an international
standard but still don't use the metric
system which makes no sense and they
made pizza papa a cameo by the great
bruce campbell long-time collaborator
with sam rainey from evil dead films in
the spider-man trilogy strange leaves
him in a spell punching himself for
weeks until it finally fades in the
post-credits scene actually there in
that scene on his car you can see a fork
this is the same fork that the tiny
ashes use on ash's butt and army of
darkness america's memory lane flashback
shows the utopian parallel from the
comics but a bee lands on her finger
causing her to freak out open portals to
suck her moms to hell honeycomb world
must have sucked for her the 838 sanctum
statue of steven strange says he gave
his life to beating thanos and calls him
earth's mightiest hero the avengers
moniker i also love how the statue was
built out in the street so all the cars
have to drive around it and look at it
the way that in washington dc you have
to drive in a roundabout to look at but
the iwo jima statue mordo explains
dreamwalking and raymie and bobaroski
edit the sequence with superimposed
crossfades elfman's moody rock music
just giving this movie a 90s witchcraft
vibe like something from the craft or
buffy the vampire slayer i don't care
what the haters on twitter say the image
of this movie rocks but mordo drugs them
with the sands of nisanti a spell from
the comics that prevents the usage of
magic for three minutes 616 wanda
dreamwalks into alternate wanda her
presence peeking out from behind the
stairs and then hiding again voyeuristic
imagery akin to john carpenter's michael
myers point of view shots at the
beginning of halloween actually if you
listen closely here notice what juana
tells the boys
[Music]
that is exactly what wanda does to
herself she turns her own voice against
her on the tv they're watching a black
and white cartoon of oswald artensia
this is a 1928 walt disney short called
the sky scrappers walt made these oswald
shorts for universal before a contract
dispute led him to launching mickey
mouse and steamboat willie oswald
meanwhile has gained a bit of a cult
following as the mickey mouse who might
have been a what if poster hero in this
what if universe notice how there are no
photos of visions around this home that
is because according to elizabeth olsen
these alternate reality wandas are
single mothers divorced from vision all
the lights flashing the wind blowing the
photo turning to look at wanda despite
being frozen in time all this horror
imagery evokes sam raimi's effects in
movies like drag me to hell the food
rolls around on the plate like in
poltergeist the tea crashes like an
ocean an ocean flooded the
post-incursion universe so we visit
later this movie making this an early
sign of how these are all leading to
incursions but after all the noise i
just love how they show the possession
finally completing with a simple silent
gesture
yes breaking the fourth wall looking at
us like the final unnerving shots of
psycho and paranormal activity sarah
stabs the 616 darkhold burning herself
alive the last part of her turning to
ash being her eye releasing a single
tear but notice her lips here she is
mouthing something as her final words to
wong and looks like she is saying the
words i love you this severs wanda's
dreamwalk link
tommy
and again the lack of sound on the inner
cutting just makes it so haunting this
is how wanda would see it just images
from her dream flickering away from her
and wanda is left with her hands in the
air just as she was in one division when
vision faded away from her wong takes
her to mountain wundigor where in the
comics the demon that elder god c'thon
inscribed the spells that were
eventually drafted into the darkhold
book this is also the mountain where in
some comics wanda and pietro were born
in the castle of the high evolutionary
nurse by bova this is also where kathan
initially cursed wanda when she's a baby
though in the 616 mcu she was born to
arena and oleg maximoff and sokovia also
in wanovision want to show that she
already had some low-level probability
hex abilities as a girl it just remains
to be seen if the mcu will trace that
back to catholics curse the temple walls
are carved to look exactly like the
scarlet witch page of the darkhold scene
in wandavision a set photo actually
showed how one of these statues shows
billy's wiccan form suggesting that
those boys were part of the scarlet
witch prophecy this temple's guards are
the ingary these are cathon's elder
spawn minions from the comics and wanda
realizes the chamber is not a tomb but a
throne the altar she stands on has that
same horned head as the darkhold book
cover perhaps being the horned form of
c'thon from the comics meanwhile
christine explains our universe is
and we've designated yours 616. yes with
this line the mcu formally codifies its
numerical designation at 616 which is
the main universe in the comics this
number was coined by captain britain
comics writer david thorpe who said in
an interview that he got that number by
subtracting the round number 50 from 666
so you know who's behind all of this 616
universe first showed up in the mcu on
celtics chalkboard in thor the dark
world it was mentioned by mysterio and
far from home though in that case must
have been a lucky coincidence since you
know he was a liar making it all up 616
also showed up on scott lang's storage
locker and end game and on the film
strip referring to the mcu timeline and
loki episode 1. now some comics fans
including ms marvel star iman valani are
very frustrated with this reveal since
many comics readers previously
understood the film universe to exist
alongside the comics universe like the
comics have referenced events in the
film's universe but as kevin feige has
said the mcu has always been meant to be
an adaptation of the comics not
something that exists in a multiverse
alongside them similar to how spider-man
into the spider-verse in that animated
film they refer to 616-1610 etc that's
all an adaptation of the numerical
destinations in the comics it's not
meant to replace them or erase them
christine says she works for the baxter
foundation named after the baxter
building the headquarters of the
fantastic board she brings up a
radiograph of his broken hand suggesting
strange's hand injury is his constant
across universes the way with great
power is a constant for peter parker's
strangest cell is labeled d23 disney
easter egg 1923 being the year walt
founded a studio in the name of the
annual conference also bucky's cell was
d23 in civil war strange asks if they're
shield or hydra but mordo confirms the
illuminati
will see you now
the illumi
yes the illuminati in the comics is a
six-member panel representing the
various corners of the marvel world tony
stark doctor strange charles and xavier
reed richards black bolt and neymar
originally black panther was invited but
he said anna at that i don't want to be
in it the baxter security is ultron
centuries voiced by actor ross marquand
who voiced ultron and what if in red
skull infinity war these centuries
looking this way imply that in 838
ultron must have successfully taken over
the same way he didn't age voltron had
duplicated himself to make these like he
did in the age of ultron events but that
the marvel heroes must have prevailed in
subduing ultron probably because they
had help from the x-men and fantastic
four so there probably is a tony stark
somewhere in this universe you'll notice
this facility is in central park and the
interior is modeled on the lobby of the
british museum in london of the many
statues that adorn it the tall female
warriors actually modeled on xena
warrior princess according to sam raimi
strange meets this movie's illuminati
mordo introduces himself as baron carl
mordo his name from the comics haley
atwell returns as captain carter her
costume and shield looking like it does
and what if
the first avenger
the music is actually a version of the
captain america theme anson mount
returns from the short-lived inhuman
series as black bolt king of the
inhumans the shauna lynch as captain
marvel apparently having swapped
missions with carol danvers and of
course the smartest man alive
reed richards of the fantastic four yes
the producers actually said they
included a deliberate doctor doom nod
here with the portal he arrives through
this is doom's time platform from the
comics so yeah somewhere in 838 there is
a victor von doom strange asks did you
guys chart in the 60s i'm sorry a nod to
the avengers being compared to the
beatles many times in the mcu and a
callback to strange's expertise in music
history from the 2016 film also the
fantastic four historically are
considered to be 60s era heroes it's
actually been theorized that they might
have existed in 616 in the 1960s
contemporaries of a younger hank pym
reid explains the larger the footprint
you leave behind the greater the risk of
an incursion an incursion occurs when
the boundary between two universes
erodes and they collide destroying one
or both this explanation comes directly
from john hickman and steve eptin's 2013
new avengers run when black panther
reassembles the illuminati to deal with
an incursion between universes this
storyline leads eventually to the 2015
secret wars crossover which is probably
where the mcu is headed then the sixth
member joins we should tell him the
truth
our final member
professor charles xavier patrick stewart
returns for the x-men films butt in a
yellow hover chair green suit and blue
and black striped tie from the animated
series the music here is ron wasserman's
theme from the 90s show now there is a
seventh chair empty and it has been
confirmed to not belong to the 838
strange according to interviews with the
screenwriter who said that it was a
mystery above his pay grade for
something marvel has in the works ahead
so i am guessing it's either a variant
black panther or more likely neymar
because neymar is expected to arrive in
wakanda forever charles uses telepathy
to flash back to the 838 infinity war
event notice his brain waves look just
like the echo waves from the 90s series
whenever he uses his psionic powers and
we see titan thanos dead with a
splintered uru blade in his chest and an
infinity gauntlet with no mind stone and
no time stone no mind stone means vision
is alive in a38 and also notice the
seven pointed ships are still standing
upright so this battle never escalated
to thanos spiking a moon at this planet
the way he does an infinity war they
were able to make short work of him much
faster 838 steven's fingertips are black
as wandas and agatha's word meaning this
guy was dipping in the dark cold but on
his chest is an interesting icon that
our buddy mt pointed out maybe an oni a
demon from japanese mythology so no
matter what this strangers into some
interesting stuff black bolt executes
them
yeah the recorded mount saying i'm sorry
several times different ways
successively louder into a shout so each
echo reflects deeper and deeper
heartbreak also in that audio mix you
can hear strange's final pained scream a
scream that stays with them after the
blast is done also notice how that sonic
blast cross dissolves back into 616
strange hearing this story in the
present it's just a very cool way of
showing how the curse of that past
stephen echoes through the multiverse
into this steven and why they fear him
so much alarms go off and in the century
security feeds you see wanda severing
many of them at the midsection and the
last one she chokes by its throat and
peers into its eyes before just pulling
its head off charles says just because
someone stumbles and loses their way
doesn't mean they're lost forever yes a
direct quote from 2014's days of future
past just because someone stumbles loses
their way it doesn't mean they're lost
forever
now wanda is covered in the oil from the
ultron sentries reminding us of when she
yanked out ultron's heart and age of
ultron and oil poured out of it like
blood it's smeared on her face the same
way pig blood is smeared on sissy's face
that can carry she unleashes hell just
like carrie does reed tries to talk her
down i have children of my own i
understand your pain is their mother
still alive yes good there will be
someone left to raise them reid was
referring to his wife sue storm the
invisible woman and their children
franklin richards in valeria richards
black bolt inhales ready to strike but
one is ready for him what mouth
ah i am obsessed with this because it is
the most violent close-up we've ever
seen in the mcu so let's go through it
first one erases his mouth like neo in
the matrix which is panic inducing
enough just the thought of that causes
black bolt to make the worst mistake of
his life screaming making him the one
member of the illuminati other than
mordo whom wanda does not kill he takes
his own life his eyes bulge out then
there's a glow in his jaw from his sonic
blast ping-ponging around his mouth then
blood spurts out of its nose his skull
pops and then his eyes bleed after that
point his brain's oozing in his mask and
his tuning fork flickers out then wanda
shreds reed into string cheese actually
if you look closely on that overhead
shot as he screams each strand of his
body she is twisting it inducing as much
pain as possible maria and peggy fight
back peggy quotes steve's line haven't
you had enough
i could do this all day i could do this
all day but wanda redirects peggy's own
shield back at her severing her at the
waist when the shield wedges in the
foreground blood it drips from it and
although peggy is out of focus in the
background go frame by frame and you can
see the top half of her body does slide
off of her legs while maria's death is
the least visceral it's still pretty
insulting wanda collapses that xena
statue so that zena's face is crushing
maria delivering a kiss of death mordo
uses his vaulting boots of altor against
strange in their duel but strange cuffs
him with the sansa desanti cuff at the
last second to depower the magic blade
right before it hits his face down in
the trench mordo kicks at his head and
actually in that shot of the boot coming
in and streamed his face sam raimi
revealed it is actually a fake leg on a
broom charles enters wanda's mind trying
to stop her it's seen as this awesome
white void with just bits of rubble
representing her bombed sokovian home
that we saw in one division on a tv set
shows one division episode one the way
the dick van dyke show played on the tv
when wanda and pietro's home got bombed
in episode eight we hear an air raid
siren blaring that's the sound to signal
a bomb dropping for one of the anxiety
was the stark warhead falling in her
home forever blinking but never going
off for charles anxiety is wanda finally
catching up to him in this mind that red
smoke billows up behind him and
[Music]
it gets me every time it is even scarier
now when you can pause it because first
off the scarlet witch has a freaking
demon face like the demon face that pops
up for a few frames throughout the
exorcist i mean i'm sorry to remind you
that but it reminds me of that also you
may have seen she does not just snap his
neck she grabs the lower half of his
face and the upper half of his face and
seems to rip it in half the lower half
of his face just becomes more red smoke
actually during the sequence originally
hope van dyne wasp was drafted to appear
as part of this illuminati with hope
shrunken down flying toward wanda and
this greenwriter michael waldron said
that wanda was going to clap her hands
to swasher strange's wristwatch is a key
to open the door to the gap junction
wanda grabs america from behind and
repulsive strange's attack to incinerate
the book of ashanti for a moment the
page is open to show a star now remember
since strange's photographic memory he
could read that whole page in an instant
and know from that star that america's
innate power could defeat the scarlet
witch is inside her and remember that
which is how he knows how to motivate
her with that speech in the final battle
as wanda holds the star portal open
between the portal layers you can
actually see some different terrains
flickering in and out that just shows
how these alternate universes flash
through chaotically america gets
captured in the temple the altar she
lies on is in the shape of what is it
kids hexagon
like wanda's hex and westview of course
strange and christine gets stranded in a
post-incursion universe entering through
the same alleyway that strange arrived
into 838 one new universe and act 2
another new universe in act 3. now
presumably this is actually the universe
that 838 strange annihilated by
dreamwalking into sinister strange the
buildings are melting into inky strands
looking a lot like the visuals and what
if episode four the cars actually
include a mix of different eras there's
some old-timey buggies but also a yellow
delta 88 the car that sam raimi puts in
all of his movies from evil dead to
uncle ben's car and spider-man the land
in front of the sanctum is covered in
bones and skulls meaning that sinister
strange allowed people to gather in
front of his sanctum begging for him to
save them and he watched as they all
died and on the other side of the
sanctum is a looming red crescent in the
hickman comics the sign of an incursion
was the alternate universe depicted as a
giant red planet in the horizon inside
strange meets sinister strange telling
him we had a sister
donna she died when we were kids we were
playing on a frozen lake
she fell through the ice i couldn't save
her now in the comics strange's sister
donna died while swimming in a pool but
if you think about it wanting to save a
girl crashing through ice motivates why
strange wants to save america chavez so
bad her portals are designed to look
like ice cracking ice through which she
drowns for strange america represents
the sister donna whom he lost through
the ice sinister strange opens a third
eye on his forehead strange sometimes
has a third eye in the comics as a
manifestation of the eye of agamotto and
it is the mystical sight that the
ancient one referred to when she touched
this spot on his head open your eye
but here the eye represents the twisted
evil of the darkhold the eye of catholic
that we saw on the page and on the wall
of the temple an eye that lives on at
the end of this movie as they do with
each other the magic is in these
competing color tones 616 strange with
orange sinister strange with purple the
same color as agatha's dark sorcery
which may come from the dark dimension
with drama in an amazing sequence
actually inspired by danny elfman
thinking that sam raimi would shoot it
down they weaponize music and it rules
[Applause]
[Music]
yes the piano chord that previously
represented strange's fear of wanda
because we heard this discordant note
every time we were creeped out by her
[Music]
strange instead shows his mastery of
this fear by weaponizing the music to
combat the evil one specific note dart
cuts through the strap around the dark
hole and then sinister strange defends
himself by creating a measure to contain
all these notes
[Music]
and i like how as he conjures that
measure it makes the sound of horns
every move of this battle uses a
different part of the orchestra and he
probably got in there that was the
famous riff of johan sebastian bach but
then this leads to a volley between the
two of them
yes and there was beethoven symphony
number five and the final percussions
used the snare drum strange defeats
sinister strange by using another
musical instrument in the scene that
sinister strange didn't notice the harp
just one little note to explode all the
other notes blasting since the strange
out the window impaling him like saruman
in return of the king strange flips to a
dark cold page to one illuminating these
crimson skeletons representing the souls
of the damned that he will use to
dreamwalk into defender strange's corpse
the way he rises from the dead is full
sam rainy evil dead and i love it the
shot of manhattan from the 616 rooftop
actually keeps the met life building
which in the mcu has been where avengers
tower is normally located but it really
just seems like phase four titles these
days for now have given up placing
avengers tower in the new york skyline
now one of the souls of the damned is a
vocal cameo by the movie's producer
richie palmer we see strange being
dragged under and we learn later this
does have lasting consequences in the
final shot of the film the souls spill
over into the incursion universe but
strange is able to vanquish them
where's your pop alive
go back to hell
yes this is the same artifact strange
trying to use on kaiselius in the 2016
film you don't know how to use that do
you uh
that is why kaiselius was a little
nervous there this thing could have
banished him to hell and yes it is
important that strange says hell here
i'll explain why later christine tells
strange they're spirits
[Music]
yes in addition to defender strange's
corpse just being really smart economy
and story we were wondering why he was
cloakless in the opening scene but this
serves a function as well because
logically mount wondegor must be off
limits to sorcerers otherwise they'd be
there all the time trying to destroy it
one requires evil darkhold sorcery to
access it so it gives us this awesome
opportunity to turn the souls of the
damned into a cloak of levitation and
yes i love how danny elfman shreds on
electric guitar here setting up the
guitar we hear in the final shot of the
film when strange suffers the
consequences of this unholy pairing
[Music]
wong stabs the big angry with this kunai
the same weapon gargantos blocked
earlier when its wanda eye was solely
focused on him but now that wanda's eye
is on strange and she assumes wong is
dead he's able to hit the bullseye
defender strange spreads his cloak
[Music]
yes the damned voices cackle and cheer
with glee which at first comes off like
they're just love and being part of this
but if you think about it they're
actually celebrating their claiming of
strange's soul wanda shouts three more
thing you hypocrite yeah just like
hycilius shouted at the ancient one for
using dark dimension magic in the 2016
film hypocrite
strange finds himself in the same moral
quandary that defender strange wasn't
before and i love how this realization
happens as he is in the body of that
[ __ ] we think he's gonna go through
with sacrifice in america america's even
okay with it but instead he says every
time you opened a portal you sent us
exactly where we needed to go and we
realized what makes this strange
different from defender strange is that
this 616 strange went through something
the others did not an infinity war
conflict in which he lost he had to look
at 14 million 605 futures and he found
the one correct path the path that led
him to where he is now and a path that
still extends forward so unlike 838
strange who always felt fomo seeking a
better life and corrupted his soul and
killed trillions with the dark hole to
do this six zone six strange after
meeting sinister strange has seen the
dark path that leads to so this guy has
instead learned to trust his current
path regardless of the guilt he feels
for being on it and the sacrifices he's
made to walk it so he empowers america
to punch the hell out of wanda her star
portals again show a variety of
landscapes but her second hit closed
them off to only one the lava river hell
that we saw before the fact that we see
it twice in this movie suggests that
this is a key realm in the mcu where the
souls of the damned originates where
k-thon may reside and probably the
dominion of this a-hole but america
changes her tactic i can't beat you
so i'll give you what you want and she
punches wanda into her living room with
her sons letting them see her for who
she is you'll notice the way they see
her choking america is the same pose
thanos choked wanda with in infinity war
also notice on the tv is snow white and
seven dwarves disney's first animated
feature length film a contrast to the
oswald short that previously played on
this tv in this movie's villain is an
evil witch making wanda especially scary
to these boys before she told them don't
make mom out to be the bad guy and
that's exactly what she's done to
herself and these boys defend their mom
stop it
yeah elizabeth olsen said that these
boys threw something that hit her in the
face and her stomach was genuine anger
which she used as an actor to scare the
crap out of these kids that she felt
really bad about it she tries to explain
i would never hurt you
never
i would never hurt anyone i'm not a
monster
but this time wanda cannot bring herself
to say that she is a mother yet 838
wanda forgives her no
and wanda finally seeing the air of her
ways destroys the temple but as it falls
there is a burst of red magic that might
be her transporting to a new universe or
escaping into a pocket reality either
way i'm pretty confident wanda will
return at some point america and wong
portaled a rescue stranger christine
from the incursion sanctum from a
mountaintop which some are calling a
continuity error since we saw american
huang escape back to camarata from the
temple but to be fair america had no
idea where strange and christine were
banished to so she and wong may have
been portaling around to a ton of places
and universes looking for strange and
then they went back to the scene of the
crime and maybe were able to figure out
from there oh there's an incursion
universe where they must be now i don't
know it doesn't make a lot of sense but
that's okay america stays behind as a
sorcerer in training at camartage and
strange gives wong the respectful bow
that strange had previously denied the
sorcerer's spree strange fixes the
broken watch face the camera lens buried
behind the whirring gears going from a
cracked face to the watch to clarity but
rather than wearing it notice he tucks
it away in a drawer which is where he
first lifted this wristwatch from in the
2016 film back when he had a ton of
watches representing his interest in a
lot of ladies the fact that he puts it
away now fixed shows how he has finally
moved on from christine his morning
stroll turns into a nightmare
wong did warn him about this how are you
feeling why do you ask you use the dark
coded dreamwalk into your own cards oh
yeah right there the screenwriter said
that they considered an alternate ending
which would have made the context of
this a bit clearer in which we would
have seen the 616 strange trapped in the
incursion universe as back in 616
sinister strange of the third eye turns
to camera and smiles as we hear a
vincent price laugh like the final shot
of thriller the idea was 6-6 strange and
sinister strange have swapped places and
while that is not obvious here that
seems to at least be the subtext the
third eye means that strange has a
lingering attachment to the souls of the
damned these souls were shared in a 616
universe and they spilled over in the
post-incursion universe they are not
specific to any one reality but rather
they come from one single realm that is
shared among all of these universes and
that realm in christine's own words is
hell therefore despite the darkhold's
destruction strange's soul remains an
open gateway allowing sinister strange
to dreamwalk into his body here so when
clea appears in the post-credits scene
to take this three-eyed strange to the
dark dimension to deal with an incursion
this is not a team-up of heroes my
friends but a team-up of sinister forces
that is all the new stuff i spotted in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness follow me on instagram and
twitter ea boss follow the new rockstar
subscribe to rockstar for more analysis
of everything you love thank you so much
for watching bye
[Music]
you